لذلك أنا هولي ولدت في
مستشفى زارا بالشارقة ، أبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا
، لقد عشت في الإمارات العربية المتحدة طوال حياتي ،
نعم ، لذا فإن بعض الأشياء المفضلة لدي
هي الخروج ومشروبًا ، أذهب إلى الشاطئ.
بالخارج إلى الصحراء ، يوجد سوامي فقط
أشياء بسيطة. أنا أعرف الكثير
عن الإمارات العربية المتحدة أكثر مما أعرفه عن إنجلترا. أعرف
نفسي هنا أكثر مما أفعل ، لذا
أتمنى ألا أكون سيارة أحلامي ، فأنا
لا أعرف أنها مجرد سيارة كلاسيكية قديمة
إنها السنة ، إما أنها أفضل
سيارة كنا نقودها في الصحراء ،
إنها سيارة صلبة ، يمكنك أن أعني أن هذه السيارة قد
تم إنجازها بأكثر من نصف مليون كلفن
، ولا بأس بذلك تمامًا كما لو أن الناس
لا يتوقعون مني أن أقود
هذه الشاحنة  مقبض الأدغال الذي تحصل عليه من الرجال
يبتسمون ويحبون التصفير
على الصبي ، وهو أمر ممتع
جدًا حتى كسائق يومي عندما يشعرون أنهم
عندما يراني أي شخص في الشاحنة عندما يراني أي شخص في
الشاحنة  يشعرون أنهم يقدرون
أنني لست فقط وأستثمر نوعًا ما في
طائفتهم  كأنه قليلاً ، إنه
أبعد قليلاً عني ، لذا تأكد من أن
الشيخ زايد على ظهر
الشاحنة قد ترك ملصقًا على ذلك ، وهو
ليس فقط ليس كما لو أنه ليس
شيئًا طبيعيًا بالنسبة لذلك.  عليهم أن يروهم
تمامًا كما قلت إنهم متحمسون بعض الشيء ، فنحن نمرح
نوعًا ما في إحدى الليالي ، لكنني أحصل على
ضجة كبيرة بالإضافة إلى
الخلفيات والثقافات المختلفة الموجودة في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة مما يجعل الأمر ممتعًا للغاية حيث
تسمع الكثير من الأشخاص المختلفين
قصص من جوانب الحياة وكيف
تغير كل شيء ، لكن كل
شخص في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، كل شخص
أجنبي عنها ، كل شخص
مرتبط نوعاً ما بما لا تحصل
عليه فقط من كونك في بلدك
في بلدك ، كل شخص يرى
سحر وسحر دبي ويفكرون في
الأفق ولكن هناك الكثير في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ليس فقط شارع الشيخ زايد
وهذا يعني أن هناك الجبال
والصحراء هناك كل الأجزاء الصغيرة
من الثقافة المحلية التي تحصل على السيد.  هاو
ليس فقط الفنادق وترى
البيئة أكثر قليلاً